marlène schiappa est ce que vous êtes
mis là moi j'aimerais qu'on s'extrait un
peu du débat manichéen du je suis là je
ne suis pas mis la menace est pas un
concept mais c'est parce que bien sûr
non mais je sais à quoi vous faites et
je voudrais dire que je vous remercie
d'avoir flouté la vidéo
la première parce que moi justement
comme il a ce n'est pas un concept c'est
une personne avant de m'exprimer j'ai
fait contacter la famille de millas pour
savoir elle d'abord un comment elle
allait parce que parfois on peut se
demander aussi comment vont les gens on
parle de vivre ensemble avec un trait
d'union entre parfois on oublie aussi de
se demander les uns les autres
comment ça va comme angers les choses
difficiles qu'on partage donc je voulais
savoir par sa famille comment elle
allait 2 si les services de l'état
étaient bien mobilisés donc j'ai fait
contacter la préfecture
j'ai regardé avec l'éducation nationale
si tout était fait pour qu'elle soit re
scolarisés avec le ministre avec les
services de la préfecture si sa plainte
était bien prise en compte si elle était
bien protégé et quand j'ai été rassurée
de tout cela j'ai donc eu sa famille qui
m'a dit nous ce qu'on déplore c'est que
cette vidéo circule et on voudrait la
protéger et que son visage dans cette
vidéo ne circule pas donc merci pour
cela et ensuite
moi je suis tout à fait je défend la
laïcité je défends le droit de critiquer
les religions il n'y a pas de blasphème
en france il n'y a pas de délit de
blasphème en france on peut parfaitement
critiquer les religions y compris avec
des propos moqueurs des propos virulents
et au delà de ce débat je voudrais dire
que rien rien rien au monde ne justifie
qu'on menace de l'or ou qu'on harcèle
une jeune fille de 16 ans où un jeune
homme ou qui que ce soit de quel âge au
demeurant
alors je vais vous dire moi j'ai
d'ailleurs jean messia vous m'avez
attaqué d'ailleurs parce que moi j'avais
donné un petit peu mon avis sur sur
village avait dit exactement comme la
ministre bien sûr on condamner toutes
les formes voilà de de menaces qu'elle a
pu recevoir et de et de menaces de bord
bien entendu ça tout le monde les
condamne ça fait l'unanimité ici encore
la semaine dernière
moi j'ai juste donné mon avis j'ai juste
dit que moi c'est vrai après il ya le
droit au blasphème philly que moi les
blagues ou les
que ce soit les blagues ou que ce soit
les insultes sur les religions me
dérange
voilà après c'est mon avis voilà chacun
je peux le dire voilà c'est tout c'est
certes provocation là me dérange voilà
c'est tout après voilà genlissiens vous
avez réagi puisque regarder on a on a là
la vidéo mais c'est vrai que j'aime pas
trop qu'on rigole sur les religions
après voilà où on insulte les religions
après c'est vrai que c'est le droit au
blasphème dans tout cas je pense qu' il
ferait mieux de se calmer et dé rester
dans son coin pour que tout va rentrer
dans l'ordre
on croit rêver donc série là nous là
oublient que cette jeune fille et menacé
de mort par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
au point d'être sous protection
policière et il va se déchaîner sur un
détail sur ce qu'elle a dit suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que ça c'est un
discours qui est exclusivement taillé
pour l'islam
ça aurait été le judaïsme ou le
christianisme personnes
d'abord on n'aurait pas été sur ce
plateau en train d'en parler et a essayé
de nous là on aura probablement pas dire
la même chose donc là c'est parce que
c'est l'islam et parce que ça prouve
effectivement l'islamisation de la
france balances ton post avait fait un
sondage qu'il a fait circuler sur
twitter etes-vous pour ou contre millas
et les ceux qui étaient contre millas
représenté 55% pour à peu près 55 mille
électeurs
donc effectivement hanouna va pas aller
à l'encontre de ce qui le regarde mais
alors vous êtes trompés sur les chiffres
puisque je ne suis pas milla est arrivé
en tête un an dans cette émission si si
si si c'est pas sur twitter voici et
même plus que 50 sur ses puces étaient
70 voilà bon c'est pas grave les ti
alors non mais alors je suis arrivé
ainsi que jérôme anger vous l'auriez
donc l'agent le dirait que vous avez
fait jusque là sur ce que sur ce que je
viens de voir
je vous le dis moi j'aurais fait
exactement pareil s'il y avait six avait
concerné la voilà la religion juive ou
la religion chrétienne joli ça me
dérange un peu près bien sûr on condamne
tous les menaces de mort et oui mais la
ville doit d'ivoire qui marche aussi si
je les dis non pas dans l'extrait que
google parce que monsieur décide coûtera
ni les choses alors nous il ya beaucoup
de gens sur twitter qu'ils ont fait
comme jean messia qui n'ont pas vu
l'émission et qui ont voilà qui se sont
arrêtés sur sa voulais juste mais je
veux plus par rapport à la faire parce
que en fait on fait démarrer cette
affaire me là au moment où elle pose ta
vidéo
il faut savoir qu'avant cette vidéo elle
s'est fait violemment attaqué par
quelqu'un qui ait eu des propos
homophobes qui la tenaille sur son
identité sexuelle il est au nom de
l'islam on l'a lu
en islam tu es une grint est une [ __ ]
sûrs à brûler en enfer et donc il l'a
attaqué dans son identité sexuelle
au nom de la religion est donc en fait
la vidéo de millas et la réponse du
berger à la bergère
c'est à dire qu'elle l'a attaquée sur
son identité religieuse justifer
l'histoire à chaque jour ici parce qu'on
a lâché c'est madame siamois on a
peut-être et je constate d'ailleurs que
madame g dont justement il sera
silencieux au nez mais c'est normal et
je réponds très grièvement
j'ai expliqué à l'instant comment
j'avais procédé 1 avant de me dire
j'aime précipiter pour faire un tweet
parce que je vois qu'il ya des choses
qui monte donc je veux m'exprimer tout
de suite tout de suite je me demande
maintenant aux responsables politiques
j'ai contacté la famille de la jeune
fille parce qu'il ya des gens derrière
lé concept il ya des gens derrière les
princeps très attachée au principe je
suis attaché aussi à cette jeune fille
et moi je suis maman je sais ce que
c'est d'être une adolescente de poster
des choses sur les réseaux sociaux quels
que soient ces choses et je sais ce que
c'est personnellement d'être menacé de
mort est mise en cause mais je n'ai pas
16 ans je suis une adulte et j'ai choisi
cette vie politique mais là ce n'est pas
une adulte et notre responsabilité
d'adulte et d'assurer d'abord sa
protection bouquin je me suis assuré de
cela et quand son père m'a dit aussi
nous ce que nous ne voulons pas ce sont
des récupérations politiques
je me suis dit - temps cresson sa
politique mon rôle est dans un premier
temps de laisser cette jeune fille en
paix et de ne pas l'exprimer
publiquement et de faire mon travail
dans l'ombre est de m'assurer qu'elles
soient bien protégés et deuxièmement
quand il ya un débat de concepts je
prends la parole dans ce concept mais en
laissant la personne de me la sereine
je suis désolé mais le ce qui s'est
passé avec mila et spontanément choquant
dans gala comme pour charlie parfaite ce
que dit village encore ce que tu dis là
bas vers le haut débit via l'a7
complètement ce que dit ni la dictée non
mais là ce n'est que dix mille à ce
n'est rien de moins que les caricatures
de charlie en version verbal
voilà moi j'ai alors à tous les jours
j'en met sciemment beitia on condamne ce
qu'a été ce qui les lie les insultes
qu'elle peut à qu'elle a pu subir les
insultes homophobes
mais voilà moi je trouve et même elle
l'a dit après est là elle a eu des
propos très vulgaire et elle a eu des
propos qui sont inadmissibles a menacé
de mort
messiaen là le choc
monde année on va maintenant mais le
gars ne vit pas sous protection
policière
la cour l'a condamné ici c'est une
adolescente de sarlat avoir oui c'est ça
assez de morts que vous ayez saison au
sein d'une adolescente juste hassan
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous qu'est
ce que j'en pense je suis père de
famille j'ai trois enfants
si j'avais une fille de 16 ans qui
insultent 1 milliard 400 millions de
personnes la première chose que je ferai
c'est lui couper le wifi lui mettre mon
pied au cul voilà on sait pas un
milliard 400 millions personnes en
insultant la violence n'est pas sans
rappeler ses divergences internes c'est
ça la loi n'ont pas de violence
éducative
oui mais je vais demeurer saison ce sont
leurs édifiant de progresser mais madame
chipant à force de systématiquement
réglementé l'éducation familiale vous
avez des structures et la cellule
familiale et c'est absolument gens bien
vous savez vous étendez qui est décrite
et parce que ce n'est la bleue et la
main mais voyez maintenant ces dernières
demandent et certaines études mais
donner encourait alors précisé me
maltraiter des enfants battus tous les
chalabrais vient en réalité pas
raisonner sur les enfants peuvent
s'adonner fera pas les enfants oui
c'était je m'efface et madame laborde
niçois la wii a tendance à sa merci